i think he'll try to not play into the  main lines and so we might see something  like c4  this is this is the the key move yeah  against magnus age 10. yeah this is the  move that beats  the mouse slip variation he tried to  play the english he slipped and he's  played c3 is it an annoying opening move  it's not an amazing first move because  it doesn't really increase your options  as white now we're transposing into  pretty much a queen's pawn opening but  white hasn't gone for the most direct uh  kind of most ambitious attempts white  hasn't really seized space white hasn't  really developed any pieces but as simon  mentioned this is a bit of a secret  nugget of information if you want to  beat magnus h10 on the app  one c3 simon used it simon actually  slipped but beeping up and then i used  it to win as well so yeah  he's got a good track record maybe  magnus has been watching your game yeah  trying to beat himself at age 10.  i don't even know what an app is i'm not